what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into a flash the
story of faster than thought and this is
actually really really cool
all right here's something that I like
about this initially I didn't really
know what like Joshua Williamson and
company were shooting for it when they
were starting out the various forces
that were out there I mean I knew it was
gonna be something akin to like Jeff
John's expansion of the Green Lantern
mythos but I didn't really know how far
it was gonna go the cool thing about
this is that all these stories really do
is tell us what the forces are what they
can do when somebody possesses them and
then eventually it'll go on towards some
bigger thing later on down the line but
it's kind of cool because you could
easily see these forces kind of
gathering together they're like fighting
Manhattan or sewing along those lines
who knows but but the cool thing about
this and this is actually kind of a
throwback it's actually really smart the
Williamson does this this is a throwback
to the old like team-up comic from back
in the day when the flash is teaming up
with Wonder Woman in Justice League dark
in order to take down Solomon Grundy
this kind of throws back in the sense
that it kind of picks up that way and
then it jumps directly into into the
flash himself now of course iris is
meeting with a couple other people and
she kind of cracks the joke up hey you
know Barry's like he's never on time for
anything so he'll be here at some point
along the line but what he kind of does
and it's actually kind of interesting
Barry takes a few liberties here and the
reason why is because remember Solomon
Grundy's basically a zombie
so Barry can get away with things that
he wouldn't normally be able to get away
with in this instance he vibrates
himself at such a speed that when
solomon grundy punches him he basically
explodes but he just makes solomon
grundy blow up now solomon grundy will
come back Meneses whole thing but it is
kind of cool to see how easy the flash
could kill a person if he chose to but
nonetheless from this point we kind of
switch over to iron Heights we need have
Barry that meets with you know with Iris
and them and so on but we pick up with
iron Heights where heat wave basically
goes in like where McCrory goes into his
cell and almost as soon as he does like
there's this massive explosion of fire
and literally he's almost totally
incinerated and it's kind of a crazy
thing because in this moment you in turn
have Barry who starts having like these
hallucinations in his mind and these
hallucinations come in the form of him
basically seeing like Wally West kind of
taunting him and saying why did you let
them take me and so on and so forth now
again the the continuity of this is a
little fuzzy
this right here indicates that it takes
place after the events of heroes in
crisis part two but at the same time
there's no real reference to it and so
it seems like it just hasn't happened
yet so if anything this seems more the
idea of like
Wally's basically gone and he's at
Sanctuary now and that's really it but
again it's it's kind of fuzzy in terms
of when his continuity happens
but very hallucinating this beery having
these experiences seems kind of strange
to him again it's a little bit of an
interesting thing there but with very
showing up to iron Heights and basically
meeting with warden wolf you know warden
wolf basically says look heatwaves
entire cells just like exploded with
fire he's sitting in a hospital right
now and then that's when we switch over
to heatwave himself who's basically kind
of trapped in like this other dimension
this other place where everything is
completely and totally burned to a crisp
as it was kind of crazy to see because
in that moment where you end up having
like the iron Heights for cops to show
up and they basically are guarding
guarding heatwave in response to that
you end up having like these fire
figures that manifests directly in front
of them very switches them to the flash
he races over he tries to rescue him and
then he alongside Detective burns are
basically like whisked away like it
seems like they're almost incinerated
when warrior rory kind of like flares up
and then of course they end up waking up
in the same place that Rory's at and
that's why things are kind of cool
because of this moment they're met with
like this giant flame persona of
heatwave who kind of taunts him and
talks to him and says hey look you know
in this world that you're in you're in
my mind and in the in my mind I am
absolutely God now this is a cool thing
because remember the different forces
deal with different aspects of things so
the strength force / it pertains to
strength hence the reason why the flash
became like super strong became an
Incredible Hulk basically then you have
the sage force which deals with the mind
and so what this tells us is the sage
force has bonded itself directly to
heatwave which is kind of cool because
in response to that with Barry doing the
best he can and fending off against
heatwave it really is one of those
things were in his mind he's got my heat
wave is virtually indestructible now
where he leaves and he goes to take off
towards Central City detective burns
panics for a minute she says what we
have to get over there otherwise
everybody's gonna die
and this is when the intelligence of
Barry Allen kicks in but he kind of sits
down and analyzes everything it says
this isn't right the people here in this
location have been totally incinerated
by heatwave but heat wave was never
about killing people and that's an
important thing to bear in mind and it's
really really cool that that that Joshua
Williamson plays on that because with
heatwave along with the other Rogues it
was more about committing crimes and
maybe instilling fear a little bit kind
of freaking people out but it was never
about killing anybody it was like the
Creed of the ropes and that's one of the
reasons why there was always as kind of
unwritten respect between Barry Allen
and the Rogues themselves because they
never they would never kill but
nonetheless you know it's kind of a cool
moment here but of course it's also
basically everybody else realizing or at
least with regards to
Wolfen and these guys realizing that
Barry and detective burns are stuck in
the mine of heat
now warden wolf doesn't realize this
right off the bat instead it actually
ends up taking commander cold stepping
in and literally saving him in order to
keep that for you know for him to kind
of begin to slowly pick up on what's
going on but he's always kind of left is
like the odd man out he's always kind of
the guy that never really knows what's
going on because no one ever really
tells me anything and there's no reason
for him to now the other thing about
this is that Barry Allen has this really
really cool line of logic that he comes
up with right like I'm gonna do a little
bit of side tracking here following the
events of of Christ's on Infinite Earths
Barry Allen was basically believed to
have been dead right like it was it was
believed that he was essentially killed
now he did return a couple times after
crisis on Infinite Earths but that was
his return coming by way of him being
time displaced following crisis on
Infinite Earths when you go into
Infinite Crisis and you go into final
crisis that's when you really begin to
realize that very stuck inside the Speed
Force now you don't actually get that
revelation until Final Crisis and then
going into the original flash rebirth
story with geoff johns
but barry being trapped inside inside
the Speed Force and him being able to
escape was based on the idea that he
needed what he called a lightning rod
something that he could basically look
to and then say that's my anchor home
that's my compass that points north
that's what he needed and that would
allow him to basically whenever he was
trapped in the Speed Force to ultimately
escape and so following that following
this line of logic what he says is that
this sage force is basically like the
Speed Force except it focuses on the
power of the mind instead of the power
of speed and so if all things are being
equal then what needs to happen here
what what heat wave has to find is his
own lightning rod the thing that kind of
brings him home that grounds him and
reminds him who he is so he doesn't get
lost in this world that he's in and so
when Barry and detective burns start
going through and start looking at these
different things one of the things I'm
sorry dr. burns rather ya know I keep
saying detective dr. burns keeps looking
through one of the things she says is
like she was brought in as a doctor kind
of a psychiatrist for it for heatwave in
order to have someone that could try to
try to turn him into becoming a better
guy and so with her having this kind of
empathic connection between the two of
them that in turn becomes a president
becomes kind of a prevalent moment in
the story itself when she realized this
empathic connection when that happens
and almost kind of like Otto's auto
defense device kicks in and tries to
push them away the question is where's
that defense mechanism coming from is it
from heat waves mine or from some other
factor and so of course then you pick up
with iris who basically travels back to
the apartment of Wally where commander
cold is staying only to find out that
you turn the place into a giant lab
now this of course coincides with
commander cold having taken the bodies
of Barry and burns and heatwave out of
iron Heights and then bringing him back
there in order to kind of hook them up
put them in stasis so they could
basically go through the entire process
but one of the things that he says here
that the commander Colt says here is
this is all happening inside the mind of
heatwave the minds are separated from
the bodies if heatwave were to be killed
if they were to just kind of be yanked
out it would be like yanking your brain
out of your head you would die there'd
be no way to bring you back from that
and so he just kind of has to let the
whole process unfold organically let
that battle unfold inside and hope that
they can somehow come out on top and so
with Barry and in Burns being undeterred
by what's going on in the mind of
heatwave
they eventually locate his lightning rod
which is in the form of his own home now
this is where the cool thing about about
Joshua Winston's writing and the idea
the sage forces comes into play is
because what williamson is doing is kind
of using this as a way to sort of
bootstrap back to the origins of
heatwave the way he was post-crisis
which is to say that he was a kid who
was obsessed with fire and then
ultimately said his family's house on
fire but instead of going in to rescue
them he just watched the place burned
because he was so enamored with fire now
when the new 52 happened in 2011 that
was switched up instead of him just
being a guy who was obsessed with fire
with a flame gun he could like shoot
fire out of himself and things like that
fans of the roads weren't too receptive
to it but nonetheless this is kind of a
really touching and in somewhat of an
emotional moment here because what we
end up learning is that the lightning
rod that exists there it was really heat
waves hope that like Barry would find it
because heat wave hasn't been able to
find on his own because it's the one
aspect of himself he's the most
terrified of that in reality he's the
one that got his family killed that he
set fire to the house accidentally but
instead of rescuing them and getting
them out safe and sound
he just watched them die and it's like
the one thing he's the most terrified of
is facing down his own past and that's a
very very very big deal because one of
the things that Williamson's been
hitting on a lot recently with his run
on the flash is fear of the past fear
the past with like iris West and the
sense that she's regaining a lot of the
memories that she had fear of the past
for Barry and the Sin City may repeat
his past mistakes these are all very
very important things very important
themes that go on with these characters
and so the result of this is that
heatwave initially just kind of lets his
guard down for a momentary second and
then lashes out again it's a defense
mechanism
it's his inability to face the reality
of the situation that this is a part of
who he is
that he led all this to happen and so
what do you attempt to do is destroy
that part of himself and flash tries to
and the reason why is because this is
really like the core part of heatwave if
he destroys this he destroys what's left
of his humanity he destroys what's left
of him or any semblance of possibly
being a good person because while this
is his lightning rod of being able to
escape back to the real world from being
trapped in his own mind it's also his
lightning rod to keep him from killing
people it's what keeps him in check if
that's destroyed who knows what kind of
person he'll become just some crazy
violent psychopathic killer
and so they concern about this with
regards to commander colt is that with
everything that goes on here the Speed
Force of Barry Allen is merging with the
sage force of heatwave and what this
means is that is amping up the sage
force and so it's kind of cool because
it means the Speed Force can can act as
a complement to the sage force in the
same way the Blue Lantern rings off
operate as a complement to the Green
Lantern rings and so with these two
things merging it means the power of the
sage force is expanding rapidly
incredibly fast and so the concern
commander colt has is if heat wave has
another kind of like outburst or another
explosion of sorts it'll eradicate all
of Central City and that's the important
thing to bear in mind here when it comes
to the sage force is that it focuses on
the the mental powers and abilities of a
particular person you know individually
and so with this happening with heat
wave having such an obsession with fire
letting off this kind of energy that's
being manifested because of the sage
force if this were to keep going say for
example Barry Allen were to die inside
the mind of heatwave then in turn the
Speed Force could potentially be trapped
in heat wave or at least Barry's portion
of it and then in turn would continue
amping amping up the sage force could go
nuclear or possibly even destroy the
world it could cause all hell break
loose and so what is up happening here
as you have commander colt who basically
freezes heatwave as best he can in the
real world nor to keep his energy from
just expanding outward to rapidly but
then iris begins to have these memories
now the memories of iris has this is
actually an interesting interesting
thing back in the 1970s and the early
1970 really around 1971 DC was looking
for a way to write iris West out but to
keep her in the back pocket and the way
to do that was to basically say she was
time-displaced
to say that iris West was actually born
in the 30th century and then was
essentially sent back in time by her
biological parents and then she was
raised by Nadine West and whatever the
husband's name was in like the 20th
century and then of course Barry ended
up meeting her it was a way to kind of
write iris out and then just see what
they could do with it later on
introduced like somebody else so of
course they wrote iris out they killed
her and then in turn that led to Barry
meeting somebody else it was an
experiment he was
test to see if Barry Allen's comics
could stand without iris but that's why
this works is because what she does is
she has memories of you know basically
memories that dr. Manhattan took away of
when she lived in the 30th century and
when she was exposed to all the
technology that was there and all the
history that was there which included
the sage force and so when she goes
through and starts analyzing all these
memories thinking about what she's
experienced and so on and so forth her
response is there's a way to get Barry
Allen out of this now remember the sage
force is still a bit ambiguous we still
don't know everything about these forces
and the reason why I say this is so
ambiguous is because what you end up
having is a sage force or this the
source of energy
that seems to grant people like
telepathy enhance their minds and so on
and so forth but when commander cold is
basically sent into the mind of heat
wave by iris West he pretends to be
captain cold and so if telepathy were a
legitimate part of the sage force you
would think it would pick up on that and
say no this guy is commander cold like
look at all the memories that he has in
his mind that I'm currently reading
about at the moment the only other way
to seem to do that that he could seem to
get around that is if you've blocked all
those memories out and the only memories
the sage force could see our memories
are really just memories he has from
like reading the stories of Captain cold
and like knowing what Captain cold did I
mean you start saying things like
remember that that that scheme that we
pulled we were in metropolis and we
basically goofed off and you know
Superman caught us and you told Superman
that he had coffee breath where Superman
probably does and like all these
different things he kind of relives
these memories and what this does is it
really kind of feeds into heat wave and
kind of brings him back to the person
that he is and says okay look you know
let's go ahead and set things to rights
and let's get out of this place let's
get back into the real world and it's
kind of cool because when when heat wave
kind of goes back to his normal self
it's the classic heat wave that we
remember it's the version with like the
the flame gun with the flamethrower gun
and you know and this this you know
really funky cool looking suit that he
has you know different little things
like that this in turn leads to the sage
force essentially like lashing out and
trying to destroy heatwave remember the
the various forces that are there the
sage force the strength force is still
force so on and so forth they're looking
for hosts they're bonding themselves to
a particular host now what Williamson
seems to be doing here is saying there
is an ideal host for each one of these
forces they just haven't found them yet
and it just happens to be that each one
of these forces are buying themselves to
like the various rogues of the flash but
it is kind of cool because what you end
up getting is like the sage force going
to attack in an intern trying to attack
Barry who basically runs in circles kind
of a throwback
the old crisis on Infinite Earths when
he sacrificed his life in order to stop
the anti-monitor
but in doing so manages to disperse the
sage force from the mind of of heatwave
and then send it back out into the
universe again now again where it goes
from here we don't know and there's no
way for berry to track it there's no way
for him to actually locate where the
sage force is he's just kind of has to
wait for it to find a new host and then
see if there's some way to basically
stop it or something on the something
along those lines again all this stuff
is new to bear he hasn't even had time
to study them yet and the only person
that really does have information about
it which is commander colt is very
hush-hush he won't tell him anything for
fear of changing the past and so in this
moment what is up happening is Barry
meets with Iris after it's all said and
done and heat waves taken back to iron
Heights and everything he ends up
meeting with iris and iris basically
says you have to do what the other
flashes told you what the other
multiversal flash has told you and go on
a force quest learn about all these
various forces that are out there and
understand them and Barry says I've
already done that and that's what I'm
going to do but the one thing that holds
him back the thing that keeps him from
doing that is iris and the reason why is
because remember up until Barry regained
his memories after touching out Wally
West who came out of the Speed Force
Barry didn't know that he and iris West
were a couple he didn't know about the
past life he didn't know about
everything before flashpoint that they
were married you know they they had the
tornado twins he didn't know about all
that kind of stuff
when the memory started flowing back to
him and when the memory started flowing
back to iris that's when he realized how
much time had been lost that's when he
realized how long they had been apart
even though they weren't supposed to do
and so his idea is I don't ever want to
leave you though like I care too much
about you I don't want to see you walk
away and her response is well you're an
idiot if you think that because I'm
coming with you which is a really cool
thing it's a really touching thing to
see iris be able to go on like this
force quest with Barry and learn about
the forces as he learns about them is
actually pretty badass I guess it's
pretty awesome and I'm pretty excited to
see it it's a good story I'm really
loving I've been loving what Joshua
Williams has been doing the flash ever
since the arts a little wonky but aside
from that like everything else seems
pretty solid but if you guys are new
here to comment explain make sure you
guys are the sub button to become part
of the rod Corps if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]